hi my name is Samuel eaves and today I
wanted to talk to you a little bit about
what areas should you invest in and also
how do you go about putting a power team
together in that chosen area whether
this be an HMO property a single net
flats whatever the property is what
areas should you be investing in and how
do you develop a power tick I speak to
so many people to say or buying the
house in Liverpool and I say while at
the pool what because my society is
moving to University in Liverpool and I
want to try and kill two birds with one
stone shoot me in the face that's the
most ridiculous thing you could possibly
do to try and kill two birds with one
stone
what typically happens is you end up
buying a bad investment property based
on feelings rather than formulas you'd
be better off to buy a property that was
purely down to it is a good investment
and then with the money you can do what
you want you can fund your son through
University Liverpool you know buying a
house that you can potentially stay in
yourself as a holiday home it just
doesn't make any sense financially so
don't do that
secondly there's those people that say
it needs to be within there now a radius
of my house I say so why oh because if
there's ever a problem I need to be able
to get there to sort it out
my response what a terrible plan a if
your plan a is I need to be able to sort
it when there's a problem or if there's
a problem guess what there will be a
problem guess what that's not financial
freedom that's called a headache it's
called a rope around your neck you're
better off to put systems in place
whereby you're never have begun the last
year I spent the whole of October in
Africa the whole of November in
California then went off to Thailand
then went to Poland if the property was
in Scotland or Birmingham or Wales
does it matter is it it'll make any
difference to me while I'm away and the
answer is no of course not because I
have systems in place that create
financial freedom passive income not
headache rope around your neck so with
that being said the first two things
I've told you what not to do are worn
don't buy in an area trying to kill two
birds with one stone it just doesn't
work
emotionally to don't feel that you have
to buy new your house so that you can be
if there's a problem because that's a
really bad plan so next question where
should you buy well you should buy one
in an area where bar you have a very
good return on investments if people
ring me up and they say Samuel I've got
a deal okay what's the deal well it's
it's near an airport okay that's
fantastic what's the return on
investment what's the rent oh well
they're actually going to build in a
train station nearby and the capital
growth is expected okay what's the
return on investment what's the rent
I've got a small box I need to put it in
oh well actually um you know the area's
very nice it's very pleasant there's a
beautiful big garden I mean it's really
pretty let me show your picture guess
what I don't care I don't want to see a
picture I don't need to see a picture
because the bottom line is it's about
this is an asset and a good asset is
something that gives you money every
single month and puts money in your back
pocket so it's got to be a high return
on investment property typically oh look
to get a a gross return on investment of
a minimum of 20% sometimes it can be 30%
or we even beyond that so it's got to be
a good return on investment next second
thing is you need a pallet in in the
area namely and most importantly you
need a good letting agents if it's a HMO
vitally important a counter solicitor
mortgage broker they can be anywhere in
the country but if your mind h em out
you're going to need a really good
letting agent in the area where they can
edit the property out they can find the
terminus they can completely manager how
do you find a good letting agent don't
ask you a bunch of letting agents do you
do HMOs and someone might site
if you hate jelas know you want to find
someone that specializes in eight ambos
and there's a few ways you can find a
good letting agent that specializing
page demos namely one go to some
networking groups around the area or
phone some local networking groups in
the area and ask them to you can go on
spare room doctor at UK and find current
landlords that are renting out their
properties you can ring them and you can
say how's it going do you fancy managing
another property in the area and you can
actually get current existing HMOs
landlords to be your letting agent
thirdly if you source a property through
an agent or through a deal packaging
service now I know all agents work
differently us ourselves if I'm passing
somebody a property on I'll always make
sure that that property has got a policy
already in the area so that's really
important there's different ways you can
do it so effectively I just needed to
get this off my chest because a lot of
people are making me go crazy by saying
things like it has to be near my house
or I'm trying to kill two birds with one
stone
it doesn't matter by anywhere where
there's a high return on investment and
make sure that you have a good HMO
letting agent in the area if it's not an
HMO just someone that can manage it and
look after it giving you financial
freedom and peace of mind light you
deserve and the reason you've got into
property in the first place that's all
for me
Samuel leaves if you've not got a copy
of my book buy low when high I would
cover a whole most two things in regards
to where to buy what to buy how to buy
Lease Option agreements no money down
deals so he's not read that book check
it out it's on Amazon by low rent high
in fact you can get it free below on the
link until then see you next time